foreign
and two and a half years into
reconciling it I am wrestling with the
question of when do you throw in the
towel and just say it's too far gone
progress isn't being made and we are
just forever going to be stuck
what up what up what up this is John
with the Dr John deloney show so glad
that you're joining us on what may be
the greatest mental health
and parenting and dating and child
raising show ever
may maybe
so glad that you're with us this is a
show about real people going through
real challenges
um in their life right now and my
promise is I'll sit with you and we will
figure out what the best the best next
right step is so if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291-1844-693-3291 or go to
John deloney.com ask a-s-k
um all right guys so
two big news's big news number one is
don't forget pre-sale my brand new book
building a non-anxious life is now for
pre-sale we're giving away a billion not
a billion a lot of cool pre-sale items
and all that which is all great and good
it makes such an important difference
if you pre-order the books 20 bucks go
to John deloney.com it makes a huge
difference across every metric if you
will pre-order it if you got people in
your life um it's about
uh the people in your life who are
struggling with chronic stress burnout
who are just anxious anxious anxious
anxious if you've listened to this show
for a while you know I just have a
different take on anxiety and really the
mental health issues in this country
that we're facing are globally really
and this is just my treaties this is the
book that I'm going to put a stamp on
and say we got to do things different
what we're doing is not working we've
got to do things different and this is
not just a philosophy book and it's not
a nerdy science book this is a clear
path
into building a non-anxious life and
getting everybody in your house peace
man and I'm just tired of watching
people burn out so go to John
deloney.com and check it out
um
man thank you so much I'm just grateful
all right here's the second thing so
here's what happened last night Kelly
Ben here's what happens here's the story
so
um
there was a big rock concert in town
last night the big punk rock show
turnstile and others were playing
and I was meeting two people here at the
building and one of them was George
Campbell and
um another buddy here in town and we
were going to drive to the show together
I was going to drive so I live about 30
minutes out in the woods and we're going
to meet at the Ramsey Solutions building
which is kind of a halfway point for
everybody
so I'm getting ready to leave getting
ready to leave can't find my keys can't
find my keys I call my wife who is
taking my kids on a kayaking trip
and I said hey I need the keys and she's
like well there I don't have them and
then she dug around in her purse and she
goes oh gosh I've got both keys I was
like oh that's okay cool I'll figure it
out so I hung up we have an old farm
truck out of our place it's not great
but I was like I'll drive the truck look
around look around go through everything
go through everything go through
everything I call her and say where are
the truck keys
she has both sets of truck keys in her
purse too we have three cars two cars in
a farm truck she has all keys in her
purse so I hung up I immediately called
George Campbell who was headed towards
the building now if you have it in where
we live in in Nashville if you build new
construction
um you have to include x number of
electric vehicle charging stations and
so George was just going to bring his
his Tesla over here and plug it in well
I caught him on the road and he came to
I said hey I need to come get me I know
I was supposed to drive but I can't and
you come get me he goes cool he heads my
way and as he gets onto the highway he
punches in my address and realizes he's
gonna end the trip three miles short
from a charge
he doesn't have enough battery but it's
too late and so he's like surely there's
like a five mile buffer or something
there wasn't
so then the car runs out of battery on
the side of the highway I mean right as
we exit the highway
and it was a climate change denier
um conservative photographers fantasy
photo to see George Campbell steering a
Prius why I pushed it down the side of
the road it was incredible I was just a
Tesla sorry Tesla yeah worse than a
Prius I was pushing a Tesla and I kept
calling to the heavens hoping hoping
that Elon would hear me he didn't
for all you conspiracy theorists out
there starlink's not listening because I
just pushed the Tesla down the highway
and then our last resort was our buddy
had a purple Kia Rio
but I'm fairly certain he started with a
rope and I don't know how three grown
men fit in that car
that we drove downtown to the punk rock
show it was incredible that's all I have
to say about that I will never push a
Tesla again as long as I live and I was
about to make the move I think I was
about to be an electric car guy did you
push it all three miles no goodness no
those those batteries are the car was so
heavy I've pushed trucks that weren't
that heavy
and I don't want to like throw shade but
George isn't like super ripped he wasn't
contributing a lot sure he was mostly
steering and videoing me as I as I
pushed
like a good Millennial guy would anyway
we survived I got him at 3am and here we
are let's go out to Little Rock Arkansas
and talk to Scott Scott bail me out dude
Dr John it's a pleasure thanks for
taking my call you got it brother what's
up man
so
I am three years uh post Affair in my
marriage and two and a half years into
reconciling it
I was the one who had the affair
um I was the one who
initiated the reconciliation I I ended
it with the the other person
and told my wife that I was committed to
us and committed to doing the work to
reconciled marriage and rebuild it into
what it was supposed to be
and uh
you know we've had our ups and downs
and at this point
two and a half years in
I am wrestling with the question of
when do you throw in the towel and just
say it's it's too far gone
um progress isn't being made and we're
just forever going to be stuck
number one thanks for laying it out that
way and this isn't going to pay your
rent but
what you're experiencing is one of the
most common conversations I have with
folks post
um
post affair
which is that sense of feeling of of
loyalty and guilt and I remember why I
love you and then one to two to three
years in
that sense of oh and now I remember why
I stepped out
or I remember how the the
the
environment was was created
and I got on a track that I made some
stupid decisions
um
when you say you're ready to throw in
the towel what what's not there that you
think should be there or you would like
to be there
well I I I mean what I need is I need
deep emotional connection and
vulnerability and intimacy with my wife
what does that mean those are buzzwords
that are like like Stitch on a picture
what does that mean
give me give me some actions
well I need her to be able to
tell me what what she is feeling I need
her to be able to tell me how she's
feeling
and communicate to me
when I am doing something that is making
her feel
less than making her feel unsafe
and I need to be able to do the same
and feel like I feel like I'm not being
punished and I need for her to come to
me confidently
and uh
and ultimately this this part is my
responsibility but I need to make sure
that I Foster an environment where she
doesn't feel like I'm punishing her
are you doing that
I think I am
um I'm certainly
certainly doing my best I
I mean I will readily admit
if you can name the stupid things that
the
the Wayward spouse has done post affair
to try to justify rationalize whatever I
mean I've probably done it it's just
and at the same time
I have been immediately I started going
to therapy and I've had a regular I've
had regular symptom therapists trying to
sort through
my own dysfunction
I mean no I'm not perfect there's a lot
of
I mean even just recently I caught
myself in the middle of an argument
where she did Express something to me
and I I was a few minutes in and I
thought you know what I'm actually
I've completely turned this around and
I've made this about me and I called
myself out at that point and said I
don't want to do that to you
and it's it's frustrating to me
because
I don't feel like I get anywhere with it
even when I do call myself out it's not
what the response of
you know see this is this is
this is how it is this is how it's
always been
and I'm just tired I got that
but can two things be true at the same
time
yes sir can it really have been how it's
been all this time and you're both
exhausted at how you respond to things
100 percent
and that's a tricky that's a tricky
place to find yourself right
because that's I mean that's that's the
act of throwing in the towel like yes I
keep I keep falling back into all
patterns I keep falling back into Old
situations and your body keeps telling
you you're not safe again and again and
again and dude I'm just so tired of
trying
I get that
have you told her directly what you just
told me
yes I have what does she say to that
um
well I mean she
puts up regard because in her mind she's
she says you're taking an easy way out
by leaving divorce as an option on the
table
and
it kind of just stops there
well if you put divorce on the table
yeah it
I mean I have
how is she supposed to Anchor into that
dude
no that's a good question I mean like
like so so you like you blew this thing
up knowing there's always two sides to a
story and I'm not saying there was an
environment I I'm sure there was
participation both sides I'm not one of
those guys okay but you stepped out it
happened
um
and then
I'm assuming there was some significant
fracture and you came back and said I'm
back in I'm one in
and she said cool and then somewhere
along the way in the last two and a half
years you put divorce back on the table
it's just hard to it's hard to Anchor
back into and here's the like I keep
having this sense tell me if I'm crazy
it almost feels like you're throwing the
towel in on Scott
um
I mean I I want to listen to that a
little bit more I I don't think that I
am I I actually
am
pretty amazed at a lot of the personal
progress that I've made in the past few
years I is she not making any
um
it's hard to say I I mean this is this
is hard to say because
what I did to her is not her fault okay
she didn't ask for it
and I cannot cannot imagine
being on the receiving end of what I did
to her
um have you forgiven you man
yeah yeah I have okay
did she forgive you
she says she has
um
you don't think so
no because it it
just stands from the past even stuff
that predates my affair
just it constantly comes up and
arguments
and I'll constantly I'll say that's not
cool it's like once you're back on the
hey we're on this track that's not cool
to bring up two and five and seven and
eight year old things
that's hard
I I constantly find out that she still
will tell people randomly
about
what I did I mean I understand that
that's her story too she's entitled to
do that
um yeah but there's some security things
yeah there's some sanctity sanctity
things that are are private and there's
some
yeah there's there's telling your story
but then there's also spreading somebody
else's shame that's that's tough
so tell me take me back take me back to
your Affair dude like what was it about
that that happened like what did that
give you
it
honestly it was
it was an ego thing it was me indulging
my ego
and
yeah but your ego needed something what
was it what'd it get it needed
connection it needed that intimacy
there was there was just a relational
hole
um I needed to feel heard I needed to
feel I had influence
I needed to feel like my words mattered
and I just
I found it in all the wrong places
temporarily
and when your wife has heard that
she agree with you or does she say no
that's not true at all I was listening
to you your words didn't matter in this
house
she she
agrees to it
and then
I I usually get met with a you have to
understand my personality just to lend
myself to that that's that's the
response that I get yeah and I don't buy
that that's not true
it's a it's a that's a choice right so I
get that frustration that you're
experiencing that's tough
or there's something about the
vulnerability when you say I need this
and the person you love says I'm not I
can't do that
yeah that's a really tough spot to be in
I mean you know just a good example uh
about 10 years ago I had a pretty
uh significant event happened that it
was
over professional and personal lines and
it had to do with my family it had to
deal with work it had to do I mean it
was not a personal failure on my part
um
and I remember just confiding in her
telling her kind of what happened part
of it involved me feeling like I did not
protect my family like I should have
and I remember just kind of being met
with a blank look on that
and at that point I just knew I said you
know told me
she is not she's not going to be here
for me when I need her
and I carried that with me
is that was it real
that was very real I still deal with it
to this day
have you talked to her about that that
moment
yeah I have what's she saying she
she says that she didn't realize how
badly was hurting me at the time
and that that that
um
what's the right word that
acknowledgment is huge but then the
actions that come after speak volumes
right
and I'm assuming there's it's like man
I'm so sorry I hurt you and then the
behavior of hurting you is just
continued
yeah and I mean it wasn't a conscious
Act of hurting me it was it felt like
indifference almost yeah
and it's sounding more and more
um I was really captivated by
some research done by the by Esther
perel a great relationship
um minds of our time who said that most
people step out for one reason and it
can be distilled onto one word and it's
alive
I felt people say heard excited desired
wanted
but I finally felt alive again
and if you feel like you're with
somebody that is just indifferent to
struggling or I know how tough it is as
a grown man to overcome all your social
conditioning to shut your mouth and just
plot ahead just to look at somebody that
you care about and love and say
hey I really think I botched this up and
I'm so sorry and they just look at you
like I don't really care
like that's brutal man
it's brutal
yeah
I I don't think that's a pass to go do
what you did and I don't think you you
would suggest that's that that was a
pass
but I don't know here's what I think I
mean you're two and a half years in
I think there's a moment when
you've heard me say this analogy but I
think y'all are here
um
where you have to turn all the lights on
turn the music off and go somewhere for
a half day and have a grown-up
conversation about are we going to keep
doing this or not
and I think in these moments
um there has to be some Crystal Crystal
Clarity on both sides
I need you to not bring up any things
from anything from the past if I say I'm
going to tell you this my wife has been
this kind of clear with me and it has
been a lifesaver for me
admittedly I was craving ways to connect
but she would say if I say this please
don't respond with the following two or
three things
because she knew I was trying to love
her the best I could in those two or
three things shut her down
and so she was that clear with me
or y'all go sit down and have a grown-up
conversation and say are we going to
continue this and if we're not we have
to be grown-ups about how we separate
this thing out
but I think you're at a place where
you're done wishing that things are
going to be different
you're tired of
tripping as you're practicing living in
a new way and then the whole past gets
rolled back out on you it just sounds
like a big mess
it is has she been in couples counseling
with you
we've done two intensives we did couples
counseling for a little bit
and uh we're not presently seeing a
couple therapists I'm I'm seeing an
individual therapist and she herself is
not seeing anybody right now okay
what does your counselor telling you to
do
a counselor is
and he's not telling me to do anything
um he's he listens
um the biggest thing that he has been
teaching me it is
to avoid taking offense easily because
when I do it
takes the focus off of what somebody's
coming at me with and it puts it on
myself and so that's actually been a
huge focus of the work that I've been
trying to do sure and is he right do you
when if your wife gives you the wrong
look it sounds like you hold her to that
look for years
I think I do yeah
or if she doesn't respond in exactly the
right way there's not a you don't have a
like a a grace period it's just all or
nothing
I wouldn't say that I have a fiery
temper I don't I don't know I don't
think I don't think it's that it's not
all or nothing it is on or off
I never yell in my house but there are
moments when my wife says something the
wrong way I I'm out bye
and I'm not leaving but I have
disassociated and now she can see it on
me
right I I wear my emotions on my sleeve
okay
so your wife can can say the wrong thing
and she can see it all over you
yeah I think she can yeah
and she also has probably learned by
this point there's no coming back
yeah I think she probably has and I
guess one of the things I want to just
point out is that
I I want
direct talk I want to know when I'm
doing something right and I want to know
what I'm doing something wrong
absolutely what does she say she won't
give you that
no she won't I told her the other day
that I feel like I've been put in a dark
room just been told to find my way to
the door that's a fair analogy I like
that and and the only way that I can
find that I'm going the wrong way is
when I stub my toe on the furniture very
fair
why won't she tell you what she needs
she says she doesn't feel safe and
there's credibility to that yeah
at some point she's going to have to be
an adult and say the safety's not going
to come back in this marriage like I'm
not gonna ever feel safe again
or give you some direction on here's the
things I'm going to need you to do so
that I feel safe
I applaud you man for coming back and I
applaud you for saying
for doing all the work you've done on
yourself I really do and I applaud you
for saying I need these things
and that's the other side to being
vulnerable is it somebody you love can
say
sorry man I can't do that or I'm not
gonna do that
or
that's just the way I am
and for everybody listening I don't buy
that in a marriage context at all I
don't buy that Hook Line and Sinker for
anybody
well that's just me I don't buy it
it's easy
but I can tell for personal experience
there were some moments when here's how
I just and here's how I interact with
the world and if I continue to interact
with the world like this my marriage
will be over
and so I had to choose that over me
which is a whole Act of getting married
in the first place
but brother Skye I here's the deal
you've put in a ton of work man
put in a ton of work and when you said
I'm back in and she said we're back in
y'all were back in
but it sounds like there's differing
degrees on who's working on what and how
who's working on who and when and all
that mess man and so at this point I
think it's a we need to go out and we
need to put it on the table do you want
to stay married to me
if you want to stay married to me here's
what I need and I really want to stay
married to you and please tell me what
you need to feel safe tell me what you
need to do these things and if you can't
tell me then behavior is a language then
you don't want to this thing to work
you just want me to be the bad guy
or you are are just hurt in a way that
I'm never going to be able to overcome
it and so be it
I did step out on you I did I did cheat
on you whatever you want to say I had to
cheat on you and if we can't come back
we can't come back but I need us to both
be adults and call it
but I think that's where we are I think
the intensives are cool when you have
therapists that moderate that I think
y'all are past that at this point I
think you're at a let's just go be
adults and let's just promise not to
shut down on each other let's promise to
write down things that we need let's
promise to have this really challenging
tough conversation to decide are we
going to give it 30 more days 60 more
days 90 more days
or are we going to just say hey man we
gave it we gave it our all and we could
never come back from what I did earlier
I'm sorry you're there man this is tough
it's tough tough tough
um My Hope Is
regardless of the baggage the challenges
that any couple going through the
situation can at least have enough
dignity and respect for themselves and
for the other the other person that
they're married to
be honest and to sit straight across
from each other eye to eye and say what
are we gonna do now
sorry my brother let me know how that
conversation goes man because uh I'm
rooting for you guys we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge
so let therapy be your map with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to California and
talk to the Great and Powerful Sharon
what's up Sharon oh my God
I can't believe that I get to talk to
the doctor right now believe believe I'm
believing it I'm embracing this no
embrace it right now dude my kids won't
even talk you're man this makes me feel
good I may call you just randomly just
so you can be that happy totally anytime
what's up my number close by well
Dr John
I'm ready and I'm sick can't even wait
this is what you're about to say
my cell phone
no you're not
you aren't I want it okay
I feel like I want to be yeah there you
go sick and tired of being on my cell
phone there you go I love that
that's huge okay why do you spend so
much time on your phone
it feels like
Escape
it feels like this sense of rest
like I'll come home from a long day of
work and I'll be like okay it's time to
take a nap
but it I will choose to go on my cell
phone instead and scroll
to get some sort of relief from it
do you have kids
no are you married
nope so it's just you the couch and the
phone
yep
do you have cats do you have cats or
dogs
um my roommates have three scary old
cats that I try to avoid do they call
themselves cat parents
oh you gotta move out of that house it's
not safe psychologically for anybody
um
can I just applaud you good for you
it's awesome how old are you
I'm 20 27 27. all right so if you could
snap your fingers you get home from work
what would you love to have happening as
you get home from work
I'd love for the things in my head that
I've wanted to do to to happen say them
out loud get them out of your head and
say them out loud
the things I want to do if you could if
you you had a picture of what your life
would be like when you were 27 what was
it
I'd like to
uh to paint to read to Adventure to get
my laundry done in a good amount of time
to rest and prepare meals and eat well
all the things you are saying are ways
that you love Sharon
so why don't you love Sharon that much
I think I I don't know I'm growing and
loving Sharon awesome
um
here's the deal I I wish this I could
give you some I've got some ideas on
what to do okay
okay but I want you to begin to frame
this as you're an addict
yeah I was wondering about that yes you
are a stone cold addict
and that's okay because you know why I
am too
I did not have social media when I took
this job and now I even got a separate
phone to have it on there I told the the
place where I work if you're gonna make
me have this like a tool I need it on a
separate phone
and
I find myself closing my door to my
bedroom to be away from the chaos and I
just start scrolling
and so I am announcing that I'm an
addict too Sharon my name is John and I
I can't control my phone usage either
so we're in this together cool
okay
sounds good so do you have to have this
like social media and all that stuff for
your work
no I don't okay
if you want to stop you have to stop
that means you gotta delete all that
crap off your phone
and I want to say I have okay deleted it
and what happens is I turn to like
Etsy or I go on venmo or I find some
other way to scroll
that even if it's not social media
can you leave your computer your laptop
at work
and here's what I'm saying at some point
you have to put some hurdles in front of
yourself and create some new habits
and it's kind of like if I'm telling
somebody hey dude the first thing you
got to do before you dig into all your
relationship issues and all this stuff
you got to quit drinking you got to quit
going to the bar and they're like yeah
but I'm just gonna like you gotta go to
the bar
and for you it's gonna be
um
not only just removing something but
you're gonna have to add things back in
now you caught you started the call by
saying I am done with this and then like
you're like well I mean I want to be
done with this
do you actually want to sit home and
paint or do you want do you wish you
were the kind of person that was like in
a romantic comedy that came home and
painted
I think I chose that as an alternate
what do you actually want to do
I want to
um
there it is you don't know and I think
you've got some ideas like I want to be
an adventurer and a painter dude I've
seen all those movies too Sharon but I
don't think you want to be any of those
things maybe you do
yeah but my guess is if you really
wanted to you would be doing those
things
yeah that's true
like I really really love playing my
guitar and so I'm always having my kids
come downstairs saying dad turn it down
please you're not like you're not 15
again and I'm like I know but I'm one
day they're gonna call they're never
gonna call but like but I I it
interrupts other things I'm doing
because I like playing
what are those things for you or have
you just created a life where you don't
have other things
it's a journey of figuring out what
those things are that's the most
Millennial thing you've said I'm just on
a journey
acting my headphones I'm just on a
journey
here's what I would love to challenge
you
I would love to challenge you for 30
days to delete them off
and to sign up for two different
classes
whether that's a jiu jitsu class whether
that's a cooking class a dance class
something
that two days a week after work you have
to go somewhere
I think there's there's been some talk
and some discussion
um I haven't read the studies myself but
I've been the the conversations have
been compelling that
our current generation of human
especially 35 and younger
spins an inordinate amount of time at
home
everybody's just at home all the time
and when you're at home all the time a
there's no real romantic connections
there's no real friendship connections
that happen and the only thing you can
do is scroll and play video games or
watch Netflix that's the only thing you
can do because you're just a home
and so and yesterday I was playing Uno
with my daughter and there's just only
so many games you can play with Uno
before I'm like dude I'm gonna set these
cards all on fire in the front yard
right there's only so much of that and
so
um
I want to challenge you to be out of
your house
but but sign up for two classes for 30
days
and do two things that you're going to
be kind of uncomfortable doing it's
gonna be a little bit weird and what
you're going to do is if you do one
athletic thing and one artistic thing
and one this thing won that thing
you're gonna find out dude I am not a
jiu jitsu person or you might find out I
love love love love this
or I'm not a dance person or I'm not a
whatever so if I say a class like that
tell me something you'd be interested in
questioning like a uh maybe like a
Ceramics or a watercolor I saw a ghost
too but I'm in I'm in whatever that
works my wife went and got her Master
Gardener certification she just wanted
to learn about gardening so she just
like went to the AG extension building
in our community and started all it's to
say is this
you can't just take something away you
got to fill it with something else
okay okay you also have to get radical
about your commitment maybe call a house
meeting and say I'm committed to
stopping scrolling and every time you'll
see me just sitting around scrolling on
my phone
I have to put x amount of dollars in the
jar
I have no apps on my phone anymore so
you have to text me you can't just DM me
okay and we're gonna have a group of
people over to the house once a week
or I'm gonna make dinner for everybody
once a week
whatever the thing is but I want you to
commit to doing signing up for two
classes of two things and do this let me
know how it goes
I would love to know what classes you're
going and then where what's happening on
the back end and that'll be your
accountability if you don't make it I'm
gonna announce to all of America there's
not that many people listening to the
show but I'm gonna tell all of them that
you didn't make it you just prefer to
scroll your life away but I don't think
that's going to be you I think you'll
got it I think you got it I
here's my commitment to you
I'm going to commit for 30 days to
leaving my who this will be hard I'm
going to leave my
work phone either at work or in my
vehicle I will not take it in my house
I have to get off of it I have to stop
um it's like one of my core thing
teachings and man those guys
who create those apps are good man
they're good they got me so I know I've
made commitments before and I've done
them for a few weeks I'm going to make
30-day commitment here we go and so I
want you to join me in this Sharon
um I've got so much crap going on that I
can assure you I'll have plenty to do
after work but you got two things
and when you catch yourself which you
will that's okay
I want you to think out loud
Sharon is worth more than a numbed out
life
Sharon is worth more than a life that we
are just netflixing away
Sharon is worth Adventure laughter Joy
athletic Endeavors whatever the things
are Sharon is worth a life well lived
but make that happen
get one of your roommates to go with you
a promiser's Adventures on the other
side of this thing that are going to be
more valuable more peaceful more healthy
than oh my gosh they're all coming to
get us aliens are real Bigfoot's not
whatever I don't know whatever you're
scrolling
let's put them away everybody listening
30-day challenge put your phones away
put them away
we'll be right back
all right let's go out to Chattanooga
Tennessee right down the road and talk
to Maria what's up Maria
hi thank you so much for taking my calls
of course I'm an incredible singer so
thank you for letting me sing your name
what's up you did great
um and thank you for your show
anytime somebody says oh you did great
that means you did terrible yeah what's
up and uh your show has helped me on and
off for the
major thanks
um for having a program like this so I'm
calling today
um because I'm struggling with balancing
out
I don't know the reasons for making a
decision to pause baby step two
so that we can help our
14 year old who attempted suicide a year
and a half ago
um find purpose focus and Hope
um whilst also not putting our family at
risk of
you know remaining in in this debt
situation so for people listening who
don't understand her reference you guys
Maria your family y'all are paying off
you're trying to get out of debt you're
trying to pay all your debts off right
yes sir and then you have a 14 year old
girl who is really struggling
yes yeah she's doing well right now um
uh quote unquote real
suicide attempt she um ended up in ICU
for three days and then
for a massive overdose of Tylenol which
would have killed her if she hadn't been
on the phone with a friend who said you
should call 9-1-1
and
um she then was admitted to this I'll
call it a stabilization facility that
caused more damage than good she was
just a news 13 year old and they put her
in there for 10 days and we had no
control over it and she was with
you know kids up to 17 years old who had
drugs and sexual and
violent abuses and all this other thing
and so now what she's dealing with is
just the trauma from that to help her
move forward but we have helped her she
did get the best
um dialectic behavioral therapy
treatment it was a full inpatient
treatment for about six to eight weeks
and she meets with a therapist weekly
and what's her official diagnostic
borderline oh oh so oh no no major
depressive disorder and generalized
anxiety and she also developed ticks and
she's not ADHD but she has a focus
problem
and we're all still thinking there's a
little bit of this lovely what is it
called opposite oppositional
um
at some point they just start throwing
everything up against a wall right right
I mean it's just like right I want you
guys to think
um
I want you guys to think outside of the
diagnosis okay
obviously she's seeing a professional so
let the professional do the professional
things
um what she needs at home
is a stable
um
yeah warm peaceful home
yep yep okay and
yeah
I was going to say yes yes that is
something that we uh she does have a
she's not just seeing as a background we
are very small very close family she's
our only child
um and we do have um
her uncle lives with us he is my brother
and he's a special needs adult and he's
fully functioning and so that that's the
family in it we don't have any other
close relatives nearby what was her
story as to as to why what led up to
because yeah that didn't happen in a
vacuum for someone that young that's
right
um we haven't gotten a direct answer
from her the way that this whole thing
started was that beginning of a seventh
grade
towards the end of seventh grade I guess
beginning of eighth grade
um we got a call one day oh sorry sorry
so her behavior started changing she
started not talking with the friends we
would normally hear her laughing and
dealing with and this was during covid
um and she started wearing like darker
clothing which were like okay you're a
teenager you're gonna try to find your
look your Vibe whatever your group
um and she just seemed a little more
Moody and disconnected from us and you
know we would do our normal things but
we just chalked it up to hormones right
wrong or indifferent and one day you
know we had an argument about what she
was wearing she just looked
floppy and slovenly and it was just like
what is going on like what is this kind
of like you got this death five look
going on you know just it's I know you I
Emo or you gossip like what is the deal
and
um we got into an argument about just
how sloppy she was looking one day and
so she went to school that day and then
in the afternoon
I got the call from the school counselor
that said I have your daughter here and
she's been cutting herself and
um you need to take care of this and we
were just mortified because this is the
kid who has access to everything
anything she wants to do not that we've
over indulged her but like for example
horses she loves horses we don't own a
horse we've never been around horses we
have paid for her to have the best
lessons as often as she needs Etc and so
it just completely pulled the rug out
from under us we found a therapist and
the therapist evaluated her on that
first date and then when she brought us
in and she said
you guys my husband and I it's just like
you guys are a helicopter parenting this
child and she needs some space you're
stifling her and we said okay we're
gonna back off tell us what you want and
she said almost I'll stop right there
how did that feel when they told you
that
we were that hard to hear we didn't
hear it we disagreed with it because our
daughter had been given a cell phone and
she knew the rules and we had told her
for your protection we are going to
monitor randomly and I told her we don't
have time we have jobs I don't want to
look at your sex I don't care I don't
look I don't want to look at my own text
I don't want to look at it hold on hold
on hold on I'm just gonna stop I'm gonna
start right there even that conversation
right there Maria is too much for a 12
year old or a 13 year old they can't
they can't cognitively process that
conversation you and I were just having
um
the therapists had said take off the
monitoring software that was a terrible
terrible terrible advice
and that's what we followed her because
she
is hold on super controlling parents and
we followed her damn advice sorry no
that's what that's what it is
yes that was Dreadful advice
but it's not in a vacuum
and even the way you've painted the
conversation about she got put in in an
inpatient when she tried like really try
to take her life
it's a mad house in there it's scary oh
but hold on but y'all aren't the victims
of that
no it's the best services that your
community happened to have to take care
of your baby girl and keep her alive
is it perfect absolutely not I've been
in there more times than I can count be
sitting with people
but to leave and go well they did all of
this stuff to us and reframe this in a
victim's light or this this you got I'm
gonna tell you right now you got
terrible advice here's what the advice
should have been no phones
a 13 year old who is trying to figure
out who she is and is spinning out of
control needs her parents to stop all
the chaos not to take the brakes off
what your kid desperately desperately
desperately needs is her mom and her dad
not hey we've got all this we've got all
this here you can you see them saying
there's a difference there and I'm not
saying any of this is causal okay none
of this caused this thing
but what I'm trying to give you as a
path
out especially in in concert with
professionals
um
and the phone go ahead go ahead see so
the just
to be clear with the timeline Within
three to four weeks after that with her
seeing this therapist few times a week
um that's when she attempts to suicide
and like call the therapist and she was
just done she was just like
so apologetic she just she said I didn't
see it coming and
you know my daughter was talking with
her so
so here here's here's the unfortunate
place we find ourselves
um
we'll link to it in the show notes
there's a what I would call a
masterpiece book by Dr Gabor mate and
his uh another child psychiatrist
um and it's something along the lines of
hold on to your kids I think it's called
see if we can find that title of that
book
um
but it's co-written with somebody else
here's here's the premise of the book
you're going to hear from mental health
professionals you're going to hear from
school officials you're gonna hear from
everybody every YouTube Yahoo news
article or whatever telling you that the
most important people in your kid's life
when they become teens is their peers
and they need more unstructured
interactive time with their peers
that's completely nonsense that's not
how their bodies are wired okay yes yep
we agree and we've learned
learned that only the in the most
the most horrible way
um and so we're in this state now where
she is she's doing well we have better
communication I won't say that it's
perfect well no I got a 13 year old it's
never perfect it's never perfect yeah
right right and I you know we do have a
good sense of humor in our family like
you know I I will tell if I mess up on
something I'll say hey man cut me some
plaque I've I've never done this before
with this with a child human first you
know so yeah is there a possibility that
you or your husband or both
could alter your work schedules to where
y'all could each have a morning
breakfast once a week with her just
alone oh we do oh my God
we've always done that yeah we have game
nights we have movie night we I've
started giving her more of my time like
I will randomly when I pick her up from
school I will do the unthinkable I will
show up with her favorite Starbucks
drink which I normally because I'm on
baby step two I'm not biased
so you know and and we end up having
just nice chats we'll go for like we'll
walk around and you know she she has
grown closer to us but there are still
she's so traumatized for her therapist
um from that experience that there are
certain things she is just terrified to
talk about even what the therapist
so we need to get to that ASAP
yeah and she's working I've shared that
with the therapist okay and you're going
to have a family session as well so we
and we do we do those periodically okay
and so my my concern on that kind of
move is and again I'm I am completely
throwing spaghetti up against a wall
here okay
okay but a kid who can't verbalize
what's happening
sometimes that means it's still
happening
sometimes that means it is so close I
don't have words for it
sometimes and again
um
it can be anything from bullying at
school that is so profound that just
isn't fully understood it can be you
have another adult male living in your
house it can be any number of things
combination of things too and anything
but getting to that
where your daughter feels safe enough to
start begin beginning to start talking
about some of this stuff
let me go back to the beginning question
here
your child's mental health and mental
well-being is more important than
getting out of debt your child being
alive is more important than
that goal right now
I'm not suggesting you go borrow a bunch
of money I don't think you need to do
that but but
yes your kids health comes first does
that mean you go buy a horse no that
doesn't mean you go buy a horse
that does mean that your kid gets a job
and begins to help out with horse
lessons or dance lessons or whatever
things you're gonna do
that does mean
like in this one phone call if you go
back and listen to it
the victim of this a victim of this and
now we're a victim of a 13 year old kid
at some point I want you Marie to take
ownership and your husband to take
ownership of this house
I I we are going to be the most
important people in the lives to our
daughter
and we're not going to do that through
Force feeding we're going to do that
through connection
and man there's all kinds of mess going
on and there's a there is a spike in
suicide the last numbers I saw
um it's been a minute since I looked at
them but it's there is a spike and there
is a Lost Sea of middle school kids like
a Lost Generation of kids who the last
few years of their elementary schools in
coveted lockdown and it's a mess I've
got a middle schooler I get it I talk to
middle school kids all the time
Mass
but I'm not going to attach all that
mess to my kid
if I got to pull my kid out of a school
I'm gonna pull my kid out of a school
and I'm not going to give my kid a
smartphone
I'm not going to give my kid unfettered
access to bullies 24 7 365 and that
hurts my child I know that it doesn't
hurt them it it makes them uncomfortable
it makes them a pariah it makes them an
outsider I get that
but the data is too clear for me
and I'm not gonna blame it I'm not going
to blame him I'm not going to blame
I want you to start thinking about
things that aren't going to be random
that might be very very structured
because it sounds like with this baby
girl could use a healthy dose of is some
significant structure on Mondays we do
this and on Tuesdays we do this and on
Wednesdays we do this and it's going to
be a practice a practicing of
structure
I think that might be good for the whole
family obviously 100 continue on with
the
um
with the with your counselor with your
therapist and for every therapist
listening for God's sake it is never the
right move for a 12 or 13 or 14 year old
for you to tell their parents actually
we need you to back off even more and
let them have unfettered access you are
overbearing checking on their phones
that's insane
absolutely insane
I'm not giving my kids access to the
open internet and all the Predators and
all the nonsense and all just had a call
a minute ago about how I can't control
myself how am I gonna expect my child to
no no thank you no thank you
Maria continue to plug in your kid man
continue to plug in and don't break the
bank
buying things
obviously pay for rehab and executive
she needs to go get go get professional
help but
um
let's sit down take a global look at
your daughter's health or mental health
all the things all all we need to do
there
let's make sure the whole family's
plugged in because there's man
something's not right something's not
sitting right with me
and hopefully the therapist can dig that
out
thanks for the call we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non his life today for just 20 bucks at
John deloney.com
all right as you wrap up today's show
I never thought I would have shine down
on this show but here we are
Kelly's third favorite band behind Tupac
and
Beyonce
songs called a symptom of Being Human
I can still remember me and Miss
November Rain beautiful and strange
always so inclined coloring Outside the
Lines yeah you are never on time hey me
neither
you're always been slightly awkward yes
kind of weird is this talking about
making at least just hurting my feelings
upside down and not all here yes what's
wrong with me and you is crystal clear
unpack all your baggage hide it in the
Attic where you hope it disappears this
all seems so familiar but it doesn't
feel like home just another unknown
Kelly
Shinedown fan love you guys stay in
school bye